Hi, this is the
lecture on ******
disorders. My name is
Dr. Adrienne Loftus.
Here are your
session objectives.
In summary, your
session objectives
are about recognizing
****** dysfunctions
and paraphilia,
what the definition
of ****** dysfunction
and paraphilia
is, and being able
to distinguish
the different
types of ******
dysfunctions as
well as recognizing
specific paraphilic
disorders.
Here's the ****** response
cycle. It's really
important to understanding
****** dysfunctions
as well as paraphilias.
You have to be
able to have a little
bit of understanding
of the ****** response
cycle. I'm not going
to go into it in detail
here but to recognize
that the two models
here, the left one being
the male model and the
right one being the
female model, these
are models that are
pretty accepted by
modern science that were
created by Masters and
Johnson's or this is
something off of Masters
and Johnson's actual
models. The four stages
that are recognized
in the ****** response
cycle are excitement,
also known as
desire, plateau,
******, and
resolution. The
thing to remember
is that there's a
disturbance somewhere
within this ******
response cycle.
It's usually within
one area of it, not
multiple, but there
can be a disturbance
in one area
that leads to a
disturbance in another.
When we're talking
about ****** dysfunction
disorders, there could
be multiple causes.
It's typically going
to be one predominating
cause. it can actually
have a secondary
cause to it so it could
be something that is
physical, psychological,
or sociocultural.
About 40% of women
have ****** dysfunction
disorders and about
30% of men and
this is an actual
worldwide statistic.
Like with any other
diagnosis or disorder
there can definitely
be symptoms
that we're going to
look for in signs.
We want to first rule
out other medical
causes such as anything
from hormone imbalance
or some kind of
chronic disease. We
definitely want to
rule those things out
first before we're
looking for those causes
I just showed you on
the last slide. And
here are some
different symptoms that
someone could
definitely have. We
could also find certain
things that we're
going to look for
on physical exam.
Any diagnosis history
and physical exam
is important to diagnosing
****** disorders
the one thing that
we probably haven't
gone over in detail
at this point
about is ****** history
and ****** history
is going to include
things like if they
are ******** active
maybe some specifics
about partners but
not necessarily too
many details and
also like protection
contraception STI's
things like that it's
also going to be how
often they're having ***
how they're having
*** and we have to get
into these specifics
because we have to
make sure that we're
not missing something
when we're trying to
make a diagnosis such as
this so I'm not going
to go into more detail
about ****** history
that will be in the
reproductive course
that you have but I will
say that we have to
make sure there are
no other causes that
are making this ******
dysfunction happen
such as depression or
diabetes neuropathy
due to hypertension or
something we have to rule
out all the stressors
and the psychosocial
things that could
be coming up medications
expectations cultural
expectations that
are put upon someone.
These things all
have to be ruled out
first to make sure
that this is a primary
****** dysfunction
because if something
else is causing this
to happen it would
then be a secondary
****** dysfunction.
Also these ******
dysfunctions aren't
something that happened
on one occasion.
You know a patient
might come say oh
this happened one
time to me. This isn't
something that we're
looking at as one
occasion. We're
looking at this having
happened over at least
six months' time.
Also, it is causing
someone distress
or disturbance
in their life.
We'll get into
that also with
paraphilias that it's
usually going to be
for at least six
months' time and
it's causing distress
or disturbance.
Someone is seeking
help or you're asking
about it and they're
worried about it.
Sometimes Sometimes
someone may want
something to happen for
a reason or not actually
are seeking help for
it. It's not causing
them distress that
they don't get *******.
That's a different
thing here than what
we're talking about.
We're talking about
someone who has had
this for at least six
months not being caused
by something else
pathological and it
is causing that person
distress. This is a
list of all the ******
dysfunctions that
we're going to go over
here. There are a few
that are not here.
Most of these, the
criteria for diagnosing
that I'm going to go
over here, can also be
found in the Diagnostic
and Statistical
Manual of Mental Disorders,
which is the DSM-5,
or on the fifth version
of that, that is
put out by the American
Psychiatric Association.
What we're talking
about is actually
the absence or reduction
of any three symptoms
that you see here,
whether it's ******
interest, thoughts and
fantasies, initiation,
****** excitement, just
not being
receptive to it,
an internal or
external arousal to
specific sensations
to the genitalia. You
have to have three
of these criteria
to actually say that
someone has this.
Also it has to
happen on almost all
occasions of ******
activity. It's not
just a one-time
thing, it has to be
something that is
consistent and constant.
At least six
months of distress
have to be
happening also.
This is how you can
say that this isn't
just something that's
a one-time thing,
I'm not interested
in it. If it is
happening again and
again over at least six
months and it is
causing that person
actual distress whether
it is specifically
to their relationship
or just the fact
that they're not
able to be *******.
The two arousal
disorders that I'm
going to talk about
are female ******
interest arousal
disorder and male
hypoactive ******
desire disorder.
Also listed on
the slide I show
the differential
diagnosis for
any type of
arousal disorder.
Remember, though, in
this case, we're looking
at primary arousal
disorders. So all of
these things have to
be ruled out first. So
on your differential,
besides having a
primary arousal disorder
for these things, you
want to rule out that
it's not being caused
by a chronic medical
condition or substance
use, any kind of other
diagnoses such as
perimenopause, anxiety
or depression, make
sure it's not some
kind of medication side
effect, and anything
else that is listed
here. You want to make
sure that these things
are not the cause of
the arousal disorders
that we're talking
about in this instance.
We're not exactly
sure why this happens.
If this is something
that people
experience more from
anxiety, we don't
know. If this is
something that goes along
with possibly an
anxiety to perform.
Again, it shouldn't
be some kind of a
medical condition,
but whether it goes
along with something
else that is
psychological, we're
not exactly sure.
There is a European
study that showed
that age makes a
difference, so being
over the age of 50
actually increases the
chance of having
****** interest
disorder, ****** interest
arousal disorder.
As I just
mentioned, you want
to make sure
that you rule out
first all these
other causes
that could be causing
this. However, there
are some etiologies
that it actually
makes the female
****** interest arousal
disorder happen. So
being perimenopausal
as well as different
psychiatric and
psychological disorders
could cause this.
But for it to be
that actual disorder,
you want to
make sure that
you've ruled out
these things first.
There is something
called the female
****** function
index. It is a survey
of questions that
you can actually ask
somebody to specifically
answer to get
an idea of whether
this could be
female ****** interest
arousal disorder.
And how do you
treat this?
Well, there's nothing
that clearly has been
shown to work. The
biggest thing is
cognitive behavioral
therapy and *** therapy.
Sometimes you'll find
that the partner may
or may not have this
also, of course there
can be just this
discrepancy in desire
between the partners
in a relationship, but
this treatment here
that you're seeing,
these are things
that can be tried,
bupropion is
something that can be
used especially in
depressive states
so it may actually
work for this
specific disorder
but there's not great
evidence to show
that it does work.
Also first starting
with lifestyle
modifications is what
I would recommend for
someone so going through
taking their history
if they are caffeine
user maybe decreasing
that if they are
alcohol user maybe
decreasing that So
those are some different
lifestyle modifications
including possibly
losing or even gaining
weight sometimes.
Topical lubricants
and moisturizers may
work or help to
actually decrease the
amount of arousal
disorder they have.
And then I already talked
about those
hormones there.
Here is male hypoactive
****** desire
disorder. They are named
a little bit differently
but in that is
because of the way
that the ****** response
works. Their ******
response is different
in males and females
so definitely
keeping this in mind.
However, this is similar
to the female ******
interest arousal
disorder in that it
could be a lack of or
recurrent deficiency
in ****** desire, ******
thoughts or fantasies.
There should be again
three of the criteria.
You can look back
and you can see those
six criteria that are
on there. It should
last for about six
months or more and then
there should be some
kind of distress that
this is causing whether
it's to the person
psychologically
or really in their
relationship that they're
finding distressful that
it could be harming
their relationship.
The female ********
disorder this is
again a different
part of the ******
response. This is a
persistence or recurrent
delay in the ability
to reach ******
following a normal
****** excitement
phase. So it has to
be following a normal
****** excitement
phase. This again
has to be something
that is consistent,
it has to be constant,
it's lasting for
most ****** episodes
for six months or more.
So the other thing
is that it is causing
some kind of distress.
It is not better
fit in another
psychological condition.
You're going to
see that a lot with
a lot of these
disorders is that, hey,
we've made sure to
rule out some kind
of other medical
cause, as well as some
other kind of
psychological condition.
A British study
showed that female
******** disorder
is probably present
prevalent in about 4
% of the population.
This number could
probably be higher than
that. We don't have
the greatest study on
this, but definitely
there are people
working on researching
this more. A lot of
this is because it's
either looking back at
what people have
actually admitted to as
far as their symptoms
and then putting that
together, or *******
pelvic pain and
*********** disorder,
it's actually something
I see not uncommonly
as an OBGYN. And it
also is seen by
psychiatrists, so because
it can have both a
physiologic, physical
type complaint to it,
but as well, it can
be based in a psychologic
type complaint.
So there are several
things about this.
So number one, it's a
descriptive disorder.
it is not only the
ability to not have
*********** or difficulty
having ***********
it is actually a
******* type pain a
pelvic type pain
there is fear of pain
because of the previous
types of attempts to
try to have ***********
and having pain
fear of pain from just
someone being in the
area of the genitalia,
but also for
vaginal ***********.
There's also attention
of the pelvic floor
muscles. So this can
be anywhere from
the introitus or the
external genitalia
to actually trying to
********* and go inside
and deep ***********.
Again, this has to
be happening for at
least six months.
It causes a distress
usually to the
patient. Sometimes it
also causes distress
to the partner too
because they see
their partner in pain.
And it can have
multiple etiologies
as I was mentioning.
It can be both
physiologic as well
as psychologic.
There are two things that
used to be called
dyspareunia.
Dyspareunia is
now referred to as
genitopelvic pain and
vaginismus. Vaginismus
is now known as
*********** disorder.
So dyspareunia was
the pain of the
pelvis and vaginismus
was actually
contraction or tightening
of the vagina on
***********, a
*********** disorder.
In North America,
studies show that
actually about 15
% of women could
be experiencing
pelvic pain or
recurrent pain
during ***********.
The etiology is
not well known. It
is not known to be
genetic. However,
in this psychologically
based, it could be
due to actual physical
trauma such as ******
***** or physical
***** and trauma but it
could also be due to
anxiety or depression.
It definitely takes
a detailed history as
far as a gynecological,
psychiatric and
a urological history
are important in this
because they can all
be basis for this.
So when we look at
the two different
portions of this
disorder, the *******
pelvic versus the
penetrative disorder,
the treatments are
going to differ.
And I noticed just
now it has DSM-4.
Sorry about that.
But the DSM-5 has
not changed. The
treatment is the same.
So the treatment
for the *******
pelvic pain is going
to be more of cognitive
behavioral therapy.
there can be
creams and lubricants
that are used.
Physical therapy,
I send patients to
physical therapists
for this who
actually not only
take the time and
also have the discussion
as far as what
is helping them
as they go along.
Treating any
underlying etiology,
such as if someone
has a recurrent yeast
infection that
they have not been
treated for, that
can be actually what
is causing them
to have the pain.
So getting rid of
that. The prognosis
is going to be
variable depending
on what kind of
diagnosis they have
that may be causing
this to go on.
But in the
penetrative disorder,
these are again the
same types of treatment
you see though that
benzos may be used here
and that's because a
lot of the penetrative
disorder may be anxiety
-based, PTSD-based,
and OMM. OMM can be
used actually in both.
The prognosis though
is better with
appropriate treatment
and penetrative disorder.
Next we get into male
erectile disorder
and DSM-5 says that
this is something that
is a persistent or
recurrent inability
to attain or to
maintain an adequate
********. So it's not
just to get an ********,
but it's to maintain
an ******** also.
And it's not that
it occurs one time.
It has to be occurring
75 to 100% of the
times during ******
activities that the
patient, the male
patient is involved in.
Again, has to be
occurring for at least
six months. It has to
cause distress to at
least the patient.
If not the patient,
maybe it's causing
distress to the partner,
the partner is very
concerned about this,
and it's not
attributed to any
other psychological
condition.
When we're talking
about male erectile
disorder, age is something
that is important to
think about here. It
can start as early as
20 years old, so we
shouldn't put off what
someone brings to us
as far as thinking
about and bringing up
the fact that they may
be having a problem
maintaining an ********.
I know that for men
this can be definitely
something that is
hard to talk about so
when if a patient is
bringing this up to you
you should definitely
ask them more questions
about it as far as
when did they find
that this is happening
how long has this
been going on and seeing
if there's any etiology
behind why this could
be happening. If
not, this could be
male erectile disorder.
Again, ****** history
and history in
general is really
important. Asking
about the patient's
psychological status,
especially if they're
on any medications
for any kind of
DSM-5 diagnoses.
Asking the patient
about their confidence
level and any social
factors that go
with this, including
embarrassment and
self-doubt, you know,
to ask a patient,
how is this affecting
your life? It's
definitely important to
get an idea of where they
are with this. The
physical exam, one other
thing to do also in
getting the history
is to do this
international inventory of
erectile function. It
is a survey and it asks
how often the patient
is getting an ********
and actually asked in
the past six months.
So it actually has
it on there for both
you as well as the
patient to remember that.
And then is it
affected by ***********
and other sort of
questions? Does this
bother you? Does this
bother your partner?
Labs. So here you could
test for testosterone
level. You can also
test for DHEAS and
see if these things
are being affected and
that whole cascade, the
testosterone cascade.
The other thing
to think about is
looking at labs for,
of course, diabetes,
cholesterol, and
things like that.
Treatment, again,
modification
of lifestyle
factors, such as
if someone has
hypertension,
talking about how
to eat healthy,
losing weight, and things
like that if
they are obese.
these things may
help them get
off medications
that help with
their erectile
dysfunction.
So I just mentioned
earlier Viagra,
I mentioned it by
its trade name,
phosphodiesterase
type 5 inhibitors or
PDE5 inhibitors. This
is something that
can help patients in
this category. And
the thing is you still
have to be careful
because you have
to see what kind of
medical history the
patient has as well as
other medications
that they're on. It
can't just be given
to anyone with this.
Also, age is
something that
is important
to think about.
CBT can help in erectile
disorder because
it actually can help
the patient to find
out what may be, if
it's not something
that is physiologic,
if it's more something
that is psychologic,
it can actually help
them to try and
overcome some barriers.
When we talk about
prognosis, if this is
something that is
acquired or something that
is from like a medical
condition, medications,
then it can definitely
have an excellent
prognosis. Something
that is more lifelong,
if it's actually more
of a, if you can't
pinpoint what exactly
is causing this,
it's going to have a
poor prognosis. The
other thing is the,
depends on the severity
of the organic
cause. Sometimes the,
using oral agents such
as PDE5 inhibitors
are likely to help,
especially if it's
milder, the more severe
it could, it could
be a little bit more
difficult to treat.
Delayed ejaculation
is the persistent or
recurrent delay or
absence of ******. Now,
something that we have to
also talk about here is
what is the normal time
period to ejaculate
in. And here's how
to think about it. So
the actual normal time
frame for a man to
ejaculate from the start
of the actual ******
*********** is 25 to 30
minutes. So the distress
in this is when someone
actually goes longer
than 25 to 30 minutes
from the actual
start of the ****** act
and is not ejaculated.
Or if someone is
actually wanting to
ejaculate and it's been
25 to 30 minutes since
that first want or
desire to ejaculate
has happened or thought
about. So that is
where the distress
in this comes in. And
again, it's not just
one time, it's occurring
majority of the
time, 75 to 100% of
the time that there
is ****** ***********.
It's unknown exactly how
often this is happening.
It's something that's
very sensitive for
men to talk about, for
physicians to bring
up. It's just not
talked about as often as
it should be in the
office. So this is,
it's really important
that we, you know,
discuss this with
patients and let them know
that it's okay to
talk about it it that
causes them to stress
to want to talk about
it but there's also
the distress of having
it at home what things
can be causing this
to happen so age is
one uh it's actually
known to happen in
earlier age for in this
etiology and again
we bring up general
medical conditions,
injuries, psychological
injuries, or problems
such as depression,
and drugs.
Again, history
and physical
exam is very important.
Prudental nerve
conduction studies
are rarely done
these days.
If you think back to
your anatomy, you can
see why this might be
an important conduction
study that used to
be done. It was done
to see how the nerve
was actually working.
So it's, again, rarely
done these days.
Changing of medications,
talking about psychological
manifestations,
education,
psychotherapy
studies. Those
are really great
treatments.
And actually, if
someone's on a medication
or substance, they have
a better prognosis.
this, being able
to change that is
easier than actually
the psychological or
if something is
medical in origin, it's
going to be a poor
prognosis due to the
usually lack of being
able to change that.
So here is *********
or early ejaculation.
this tends to occur
within one minute of
vaginal or any other
*********** or actually
before the individual
wishes it. So that's
that disturbance we
go back to. And again,
it can't just happen
one time or two
times. It has to happen
majority of the time,
two thirds of the
time to 100% of the
time, six months
of disturbance or
distress, and it's
not due to any other
disorder or found to
be affected by any
other substance or
anything like that.
Studies actually
show that average
time to ejaculation
from ***********
is actually
three minutes.
So again, this is
one of those that is
actually hard to
characterize and classify as
far as the epidemiology
because it is just
something that is not
talked about and really
great studies haven't
been done on it. So
we suspect it's about
two to three percent.
As far as the etiology,
there's minimal
evidence that shows what
the etiology is,
especially because there
aren't studies in
it. It is thought to
probably be due
psychological factors
such as anxiety or
panic disorders it could
be relationship it
could be also anger
so it's a lot of
psychological or
behavioral disorders
that may be behind this
it's kind of learned
in adolescence as a
performance anxiety
and it may continue
some people can
actually find their ways
to treat this themselves
by controlling
their anxiety or even
thought process while
having ***********.
However, a lot of
times actually needs
the help of a healthcare
professional. So
it may actually be,
there may be a genetic
component to this.
I don't know
the studies that
that comes from.
However, there
may be a genetic
component.
Again, no mysteries
here, but getting the
history, doing a
physical examination.
Psychological testing
is not required for
this diagnosis, even
though we talked about
how this could be
psychologically based.
So you don't have to
diagnose anxiety to
actually say that
this is what's going
on for them to have
********* ejaculation.
So treatment actually
can be an SSRI. So
think about how we said
in women, how this kind
of subdues their
******. Well, here is
kind of what you want to
happen just to do that
anxiety or those
thoughts of excitement.
So you actually
want to actually let
them go a little
bit longer almost
to the point of you
want them to have
a delayed ejaculation
in a sense.
CBT, there are actual
methods such as the
start stop method as
well as the squeeze
technique to help
people to train their
body to actually not
ejaculate prematurely.
Prognosis is good with
treatment with this.
Priapism you may have
heard this term before
is actually a painful
******** that's
actually persistent and
lasts more than four
hours in the absence of
****** excitation. It
can actually happen
with ****** excitation
if ejaculation is not
achieved and the ********
does not go away
so the epidemiology
it's pretty rare but
still definitely happens
it has a bimodal peak
of distribution so
it's found in children
younger than 10 and
then found in adults
between the ages of 20 to
50 so here we're just
going over the pathology
a little bit but in
a sense it's actually
engorgement of the
corpora cavernosa
blood is entering there
however the ***** *****
and the corpus
spongiosum don't actually
get enlarged or
engorged and they remain
flaccid so these are
some distinct things you
can see when you're
actually doing a physical
exam with someone with
a priapism so there
are two types of
priapism actually there's
an ischemic and then
there's a non ischemic
as you can see they
have a difference in
location and what part
of the vascular system
is involved and a an
ischemic as it sounds
as an emergency it is
always a urological
emergency and it's usually
due to comorbidities
it can also be due
to it can be acquired
due to trauma as well
as medications and
then the non ischemic
is usually due to a
trauma or it can be self
-limited as in a kind
of a psychological
price of process this is
just going a little
bit more in depth is
talking about of course
how history and physical
exam are important
but what you might
see or appreciate on
physical examination the
ischemic is going to
be more painful again
it sounds painful so
it is more painful the
non-ischemic is less
painful it's not that
it doesn't necessarily
have pain involved
but it's less painful
than an ischemic priapism
is also kind of the
pathophysiological
process that's
happening behind it is
seen here some of
the tests that you
might consider
ordering if someone
has a priapism are
stated here I think
when you're
thinking about
comorbidities that
may have this,
this makes entirely
great sense.
So how do you treat,
in either one,
whether it's an ischemic
or non-ischemic,
you want to have a
urologic consult.
Aspiration is a lot
of times how the
ischemic priapism is
treated, and for the non
-ischemic, it may be
observation or outpatient
management. It
also depends on how
long it's been going
on so the priapism
excuse me the prognosis
of priapism is 90%
of men with an
ischemic priapism if it
lasts longer than 24
hours they do not regain
the ability to have
****** ***********
so it's really important
that's why this
is a definite urologic
an emergency for an
ischemic priapism
however early relief
of priapism will return
normal flaccidity
Paraphilic disorders.
Let's move into
paraphilic disorders.
These are ******
behaviors that are
not seen as the quote
-unquote norm within
a given society.
Society sets the
parameters and that's what
we go by. Sometimes
these are even laws. So
we have to see them as
being outside of the
normal range. It
also causes distress,
whether on the patient
themselves, because they
see themselves as not
fitting within the
norm of society, or it
causes distress on the
partner or even society.
So if society says
it's not acceptable,
it causes distress
when someone is found
to have this behavior.
There are no approved FDA
treatments for
paraphilias.
Here on this slide, we
want to make sure that
we understand the
difference between a
paraphilic behavior and
a paraphilic disorder.
So this lecture is about
paraphilic disorders,
which I'll come back
to. But a paraphilic
behavior is someone
that has a ******
behavior that is kind of
not within what a society
considers normal,
quote unquote. quote.
And whatever
this behavior is,
whether it's a
****** practice or
fantasy, it actually
stimulates them.
It gives them arousal.
It gives them desire.
A disorder, on
the other hand, is
actually where someone
is experiencing that
paraphilic behavior.
They recognize they
have maybe a behavior
but that behavior is
actually causing
them distress it may
even involve *******
****** behaviors or
very extreme or dangerous
****** behaviors
typically these are
very rarely diagnosed
why because people
don't come forth with
them and say you know
I have this and this
is causing me extreme
distress, right?
They typically are
going to be diagnosed,
some of them are not
going to be diagnosed
at all, or some of
them are going to be
diagnosed based on
some type of *******
behavior or something
extreme or dangerous
that they do that
causes them to come
to the forefront by
somebody else. There
is no FDA approved
treatment for paraphilias.
The other thing is
that they have to
be this paraphilic
disorder has to be
going on for at least
six months so the
behavior has to exist
and it has to be causing
them distress for
at least six months
just as we said this
is something that's
rarely diagnosed it's
also the cause of
it is not well known
because first of
all people aren't
coming forth with it so
we don't know the
prevalence of these
behaviors and
disorders, but we're not
seeing exactly what,
we're not, there needs
to be more research
in this area as far
as what is causing
people to have this.
So is it based on
certain risk factors?
Possibly, not exactly
sure. We do know that
they are more common
in men, as you'll
see throughout this,
the paraphilia slides
that we go through,
and it could definitely
be due to not just a
paraphilic behavior,
but other behavior
disorders too that
are diagnosed in the
DSM-5. Now, as I said,
the DSM-5 is giving
us the criteria for
what a paraphilic
disorder is or behavior
even, but the
disorder itself, it
requires certain things.
So number one, it's
more than a fantasy.
It is causing
someone distress,
disabling, or depression.
It's existing for
longer than six months,
so it's not just
based on a one-time
thing. And someone
may have more than
one type. And as
we go through these
slides, you'll see
what I mean by kind
of what paraphilic
disorders are and
how they could possibly
be distressing.
Exhibitionistic
disorder is the intense
pleasure from exposure of
someone else's genitalia
or even just their
body part. So looking
at someone else and doing
this in an unsuspecting
way. That's the
other keyword here is
that person, that other
person doesn't know.
So again, this is six
months of some kind
of distress or
disturbance to whether
it's the patient who
has this or if it's
someone else Again,
it could be society.
It happens more seen
more in men versus women.
And late teens to
early adulthood is
the onset. The treatment
is usually CBT.
There are some
medications depending on
especially if you find
other behavioral disorders
that are happening
in this. The thing is
this has a high recurrence
rate. So something
to think about and
consider. Here is
voyeuristic disorder.
This is the exact opposite
of exhibitionistic
disorder. This is
someone who actually
enjoys or gets ******
arousal from observing the
unsuspecting individual
and it has the same
type of epidemiologic
characteristics except
for this is usually
onset adolescence
invest it's best if
diagnosed before someone
turns 18 years old
for treatment so treatment
actually is based
in antidepressants and
possibly therapy or
co-treatment with the
two if it's untreated
it has a poor prognosis
that's why it's
best if it's diagnosed
before the age of 18.
Fetishistic disorder
or fetishism is
actually based
in ****** arousal
from objects or
specific body parts. So
it's something
that is very broad.
It's usually the body
part or the objects
are not usually
known to be ****** or
based in neuroticism.
It's almost
exclusively men. The
onset is at puberty. And
again, that's six
months of distress.
There's no specific
treatment for this.
On the next slide,
you're going to see
frateristic disorder
or rubbing or
touching a non
-consenting individual.
This is someone who
might do this in public
a lot of times this
is where this is
happening they are trying
to be unnoticed and
actually finding
pleasure from touching
their body parts
especially their genitalia
up against someone
else without them
suspecting it so it
is kind of a crime of
opportunity because the
person who's being who's
the victim is actually
unsuspecting and
doesn't know. Sometimes
that has happened.
You'll see the same.
It's more seen in
men. Six months of
distress. This peaks
between the ages of
15 to 25 and has a
gradual decline in
frequency after that.
CBT is something that
could work here. SSRIs
may also work for
fruiteristic disorder.
Transvestic disorder.
And this is where
someone actually achieves
****** arousal or
gratification from fantasies
or urges or behaviors
of dressing in the
opposite genders
clothes now this is not
to be confused or this
is not this has nothing
to do with transgenderism
this has nothing
to do with gender
identity this is as
it is this is someone
achieving ****** arousal
from dressing in the
opposite person's
clothing opposite genders
clothing excuse me the
onset is childhood.
Again it has to be
happening for at least
six months and it's
causing distress in either
this patient's life
or maybe even a family
member or a partner's
life. It's almost
exclusively male however
there have been cases
and there are cases
of women doing this. I
don't know if this is
just under reported.
I have a feeling it
probably is because
this is something just
like other behaviors
and disorders that
people are not actually
making public and
known that they are
getting ********
******* from this so as
far as treatment
there are medications
that can definitely
be used but the best
uh treatment in this
is going to be cdt
masochism disorder
this This is
****** arousal
or gratification
from being
humiliated, dominated,
or abused, receiving it.
Again, we see the same
type of characteristics.
It usually goes somewhere
along with ******
or some of these
patients will have a
partner who has a
****** ****** disorder
it's usually onset
the onset is usually
early adulthood and
it's questionable as a
cognitive behavioral
therapy will work on
this a lot of times
patients don't
necessarily come forward
or admit to this or
get treated in the
opposite form again here
is ******. And this
is someone who is
actually giving the
*****, the humiliation
or the **********
and getting ******
gratification from it.
And there's not much
difference from the
masochistic disorder.
The thing is that
medications such as SSRIs
or luprolide may
work on ****** ******
disorder, patients with
****** ****** disorder.
Our last paraphilic
disorder is pedophilic
disorder. And this
is one that many
people have heard
about and are a little
bit familiar with
because it is
*******. The behavior
as well as the disorder
are ******* if they
are acted upon.
And because of that
illegality of it
and the social norms
that are put forth
and recognized, A
lot of times this
can cause harm to
society because it is
a child being affected
as the victim.
So what is
pedophilic disorder?
It is the ******
desire for someone
who is considered
prepubescent.
And here's a
better definition.
The person who is
experiencing pedophilic
disorder is typically
16 years old or older.
and their victim is five
years old, they have
to be, or the other
definition is they
have to be five years
older than the victim
for diagnosis. Why do
I bring this up? Is
because many times
pedophilic disorders are
being experienced,
the behavior is being
experienced for the first
time as an adolescent.
So in some adolescents
who have pedophilic
behavior, it may
become the disorder and
they're acting on it
in adolescence. So
realizing that someone
has to be five years
older than the victim
or 16 years old or
older, the victims are
usually younger than
13 years old. that's
prepubescent, right?
Does that mean that
a 13-year-old cannot
be the victim of a
pedophilic disorder?
It does not, but
they're typically
younger than,
victims are typically
younger than 13.
Remember, this is going
to cause someone
distress. It's
usually happening
longer than six months.
Many people would
argue and say one time
is enough, and we're
going by definition
here right it can be
not just having *** with
but also fondling
or oral *** okay and
in this case I think
other over all of the
other disorders the
behavior is the disorder
so it's not they're
not necessarily
completely separate the
behavior of **********
is the actual
disorder here um It is
highly resistant to
treatment, but if, you
know, someone is
diagnosed with this,
definitely we can try
therapy and medications.
So this is a recap of
your session objectives.
I think we have
defined the terms of
****** dysfunction
and paraphilias.
We actually have
distinguished some specific
****** dysfunctions,
the biggest ones,
as well as
giving diagnostic
criteria for each
of those ******
dysfunctions, as well
as a management
plan, and then
recognizing specific
paraphilic disorders.
These are my recommended
resources. You'll
see that they're Scholar
Rx Bricks. I have
read them myself and I
find that they are very
much point on. There
are very few things that
you're going to find
that are different
from a gynecological
book that goes over this
or a psychiatric book
that goes over these.
I always like to
give some suggested
supplemental resources,
as I just mentioned,
gynecological books that
go over specifically
female ****** dysfunctions,
and then the DSM
-5 guidebook is here.
The link is here if you
want to check that out
at all. It's a great
resource to be able
to pick up and look
at. and then as also
what's called the current
so current diagnosis and
treatment psychiatric
book that goes
over both ******
dysfunctions and paraphilias
if you have questions
about this lecture
please don't hesitate
to email me or reach
me on my zoom hours if
you pop on to zoom
typically I can see it
in my email so or you
can send me an email
and let me know that
you're planning on popping
on Zoom that Friday
to make sure that
I'm not in a class that
has been scheduled at
that time. You can
also reach me by phone.
You can call my phone
and leave a message.
Please go on here and
leave feedback for
this lecture. This
is how we as faculty
find out things that
are working or maybe
not working so much
and possibly even some
suggestions on how
it could be changed.